I remember when the first images of
Pennywise came out and every one of the
internet was like it looks like [ __ ]
well then teach us all myself probably
included that we just take a breath take
a moment breathe for a little bit then
pass judgment cuz this is not a valid
argument she's not
[Music]
it so it is an adaptation to the Stephen
King novel it's also technically a
remake of the miniseries that came out
back in the day and where is the novel
concentrates on a group of friends when
they were kids and as they're adults
this movie concentrates on when they're
kids they're in their little Stephen
King hometown of Derry and there's this
thing that's terrorizing the town
quietly it's not like it's openly
terrorizing the town now people are
disappearing people are dying these kids
all figure out hey we're kind of
experiencing the same thing here all the
while they're dealing with Stephen King
bullies I like that this movie nailed
what's wrong with a lot of horror movies
these days horror movies these days like
I don't know get a group of people
together have a demon or a ghost
terrorizing brinson repeat let's make it
for about five bucks let's get some
money out of the masses but Stephen King
doesn't write like that so this movie
had to be different and it is different
I love the group of losers in this movie
no matter who you are if you're
reflecting back on your time and junior
high as a kid in here it's gonna remind
you of you but really at its core to the
backbone of this movie it's not this
evil clown things terrorizing these kids
it's a character movie it's his group of
kids dealing with junior high they just
stepped into the summer season but they
deal with these horrid Stephen King
bullies Stephen King was never about
just the thing at hand the evil that
he's writing about whether it be a
vampire or ghosts there are always
deeper things that the people deal with
and it is no exception and the acting
from this young talent was quite good it
reminded me of stranger things he had
that show life is still yet to review we
just look at it you're like a lot of you
have a bright future ahead of you Fred
wolfhard was involved and he did a great
job in it betraying me when I was in
junior high he's and stranger things
which makes you wonder does he just
choose to be in good [ __ ] or does he
make good [ __ ] happen question for the
philosophers the movie has heart the
movie made me laugh and yes the movie is
quite frightening I don't know if write
names the word as much as it was intense
there were a few scenes I had my I liked
sitting where the rails are on the movie
theater so I can put my feet up my feet
were on the rail and I was pushing on
the rail cuz the scene was just getting
to me it was a very intense scene I
liked the fact that the movies doesn't
shy away from the Stephen King ISM
Stephen King has such a specific way of
portraying life and people that when you
see moments in here you're like that's a
Stephen King ISM that the movie didn't
shy away from I would say kids when
they're swimming in a lake together they
usually use for shorts abies because I
love the losers so much that I relate to
them I saw them so much it's kind of the
embodiment of my path
as I knew it that when they're swimming
in their underwear I was like god I
wouldn't get down in my underwear with
anybody I mean like not sorry guys did
we hit up the store get some shorts
speaking of Pennywise Pennywise was
great he was a straight-up creep I love
the effect they do with his eyes his
eyes look like they're glowing they're
just very pronounced no matter how dark
the scene is his eyes are very bright
and they're kind of askew making him
look a little weird the thing that I
noticed when he's talking to Georgie in
the drain waters just dripping from his
mouth and he doesn't give a [ __ ] he's
not licking his lips or wiping the water
away is that such a human thing to do
and that's just not his intention Erik
don't know when you see it there's just
more to Pennywise than scary clown and
this movie revolving around kids is
penny wise who's terrorizing kids I was
impressed with the fact that this movie
did not shy away from violence towards
kids I'm so used to movies be like Oh
children we can't hurt them I'm not
saying movies never do it I'm not saying
kids never get hurt in horror movies cuz
they do but this will be really one
scene in particular you're like oh they
showed that I just gave this movie a
level of grip not a lot of movies would
have been willing to get I will say for
a movie that has such character
development among the kids a couple of
them kind of get left in the background
and it was a bummer but you really think
about it that's 7 characters in this
movie they have to concentrate on
allowing time for the bullies allowing
time for their personal [ __ ] that
they're dealing with it actually adds to
the movie and doesn't take away from it
like apparently a lot of horror movies
think moments like that would and
dealing with penny why really this movie
was just based on the scares the monster
the scary thing I'd walk out of the
movie going it was a fresh take on a
monster movie but you give it the depth
and layers that the characters actually
get in this movie it's actually quite a
unique experience and you know one of my
main cripes that I have when there's a
movie that revolves mostly around kids
is the fact that the kids don't talk
like kids
sorry parents your kids probably a model
citizen I'm sure just know when he's
around his friends and you're not there
he does not have a pg-13 mouth he's
cursing up a storm and now you know you
heard it from me and these kids totally
do that but they don't overcook it just
a justifiable amount of cursing among
young people young friends who are
hanging out with no parents or Chaparral
guys in the end it was great it has an
interesting premise great characters
good depth good development it justifies
its runtime I hope a lot of other people
making horror movies actually look at it
and take a page out of its book and just
think I love [ __ ] good development in a
harm I guess horror movies can use that
too there's a lot more to penny wise and
just scary clown but I can't really talk
about it here I have my thoughts on that
but I feel like it infringes on spoiler
territory so I'll let you figure it out
I walked out of it saying I can't wait
to see it again it's worth watching and
definitely worth buying on blu-ray the
simplest way I can put it this movie is
a Nightmare on Elm Street Meets The
Goonies all right guys so it have you
seen it what did you think about it
whether it be the old one the new one
which do you prefer what penny wise will
keep you up at night whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]